I'd love to get out of California you
know and I said you know if people can
suggest to the Jews that they move you
know the Holy Land Arizona I think we
can move production you know a little
bit further away from the Chateau
Marmont without you know either without
an offense to history hi I'm Tim
Cavanaugh a reason TV we're here with
Joe gracias the co-founder of secret
handshake productions and a film and
television producer Joe welcome thanks
for joining us thank you very much too
Joe is one of your you're one of a
dwindling species you're a producer
who's actually active in LA and you're a
small business person who is active in
LA in which way does the state of
California make your life more miserable
Wow as a small businessman or as a
producer yeah kind of wow there's you
know there's a myriad number of ways in
which I can be made miserable I've
discovered new ones every day the things
that make producing miserable seem to
have more to do with the industry itself
with unions with a lot of personalities
involved not so much like with you know
the laws the day obviously the laws you
know affect me much more is a small
businessman what's the story why are
people leaving California if and when
Hollywood is still the center of
moviemaking in America really my
question isn't you know why why do we
have runaway production my question is
why aren't we following it the fact that
we remain here is kind of ridiculous
it's like the whole industry is a
reverse convention it's like we all stay
here most of the time and then when it's
time to work that's when we go somewhere
distance for a little while and then
come back you know it really should kind
of go the other way there's any number
of reasons why people would want to
leave California it's difficult to shoot
here it's much more expensive you know
everyone is savvy to film including
local governments kind of concerns so
permits become more expensive it just
everything becomes more expensive and of
course taxes are very high here it's
difficult to you know you in LA we're
paying something like ten percent sales
tax for example like almost at that
point now so all of this becomes you
know very expensive people are leaving
because other states are offering like
great incentives we just we shot a movie
over the summer in Michigan because
there
wearing a forty-two percent tax
incentive and so we'd be silly not to
follow not to follow this you know that
you'd not to follow this kind of you
know a benefit should California then be
doubling down on its as some people have
said in addition to the tax credit
they're offering now which applies to
productions under 75 million there's now
an argument out there to start
subsidizing even much larger production
so that you get to 200 million dollar
movies being made with a taxpayer
support all right California's into
trouble enough I think without actually
paying for a lot of movies on top of it
I mean movie seem to get made here or
were at one point without a tax
incentive but it's just now that you
know everyone is realizing that behavior
follows incentives there's certainly you
know ways to do that for some reason
they don't you know the politics of
Hollywood tend to not be such that they
put much weight behind economic you know
theories in art of the Keynesian variety
but here it is it's like every everybody
responds to these incentives regardless
of you know whether know the fact that
they you know believe them in an
abstract way when we were in Michigan
huge movies were there you know
transformers three had started up just
as we were leaving Real Steel was
shooting there which is like a 50-some
million dollar movie maybe more than
that machine gun preacher with Gerard
Butler which is also a 30 40 million
dollar range someone like that there
were a lot of like high budget movies
that had that had fled and there's a lot
of inconveniences to leave LA in terms
of like talent pool and such but people
do it we work together on this movie the
summer and we did in Michigan and now
full disclosure yes and when you flee
California you are not necessarily
fleeing your headaches there are a lot
of work rules in Michigan that are
actually even more restrictive do you
want this was in / this was a kids movie
that we were working on and in Michigan
the I believe you can correct me on this
to the child labor regs are even more
severe than they are in caliber there
more they're more difficult there so
there's a certain there's a certain
number of hours or you're allowed to
work kids and that's it and there's this
all cut you know you're working with a
lot of different or you know unions with
very strict rules
you know Michigan being the home of the
UIW it's like they certainly know how to
enforce union rules and so it's like you
know you're not fleeing those headaches
by going from one going from California
to to Michigan you're definitely not
when we're speaking about runaway
production other than the incentives
that other states offer or other
countries offer are there other reasons
why you want to shoot somewhere else oh
yeah I mean I'd love to get out of
California you know I'll i said you know
if people can suggest to the Jews that
they move you know the Holy Land Arizona
I think we can move production you know
a little bit further away from the
Chateau Marmont to that you know you
know without an offense to history I
think that that's a that's acceptable i
mean what what interests me is is is
something that is friendly to business
so i don't even need incentives if there
was a way to really accomplish more of
this of what i need to do outside of
california in Texas or Delaware or
something like that a place that
actually can will will be like I don't
know if doublers ready to put Texas for
example where it's very friendly to to
business you know it without even
incentives just that we know that it's
like we can you know we're not going to
lose as much of what we haven't you know
in you know taxes where it's like you
know corporate tax is reasonable where
it's like you know uh you know hiring
more employees is you know benefit
there's states that do that I'd what
about the spectacular vistas that open
and everywhere you look in California
mean you do have a lot of places to
shoot i will say a reduced corporate tax
can make the delaware river look much
more attractive you know I can
appreciate the ripples of oil on its
surface how much of the of the
difficulty of shooting here is unions
and work rules I mean that is difficult
but it is difficult everywhere because
you can't really make a movie above a
certain size without union involvement
it's just not possible and I mean the
incentives that you have when you're
dealing with unionized crew is their
incentive is actually to do everything I
don't want to say it the wrong way to do
everything wrong on the production it's
better if you're going into overtime
everybody let call it the golden now or
not because the Sun is right but because
that's when you're your start making
your real cash
and all of that is you know as everybody
knows your most expensive days are on
the set and a delay of an hour could be
fifteen thousand dollars and sofa or
more or a lot more depending on the I
was thinking of a small production so is
there any way to get around that well
the only way to really work non-union in
the United States is to make it a very
low budget movie um I think somewhere
under 750,000 maybe less you could
probably go non-union because they're
just not enough really to interest them
the other thought is to leave the
country which I be more than happy to do
I have no again no great need to hire
Americans I can I'll go elsewhere we've
had an opportunity recently to shoot a
movie in Hong Kong and I be I mean I
certainly hope that comes to fruition
because I'd be thrilled to get out here
they don't and see how it works we had a
Hong Kong line producer put together a
budget for us and our below the line
cost in Hong Kong was something like six
hundred thousand dollars we're here
would be over two million Wow and it's
like and they've got you know is you may
have you know seen its like Hong Kong's
gotta you know has had at least in the
past a pretty fine film industry Hong
Kong Singapore there's like a lot of
good production that's coming out of
those countries too and they're able to
do it for much more reasonable rate
they're also not there is some
subsidization that Google's that goes on
but it's not to the degree of you know
like the european film markets or
something like that which of course in
those subsidies are going away as well
so I mean everyone's kind of seeing that
there is no silly why is film financing
so screwed up I mean it is this predates
the incentives it for dates a lot of
stuff there's never been a time when
people looked at the financing of the
motion picture industry and said hey
that's really a model a straightforward
this I think it's because on every level
there's a miscommunication about what's
going on in the film industry I think
that when it comes to the studios they
treated too much like a business and it
comes to Indies they don't treat it
enough the problem is is it it's it's a
product that if you make it as best it
can possibly come out you still have no
idea whether it's going to respond to
people or not it's a problem with art
you know and it's a very very expensive
art Wow and when it comes to film
financing it's almost entirely ego-based
as well I think
you know a lot of people who you know
certainly in the studio level it's like
you know there's a lot of ego that goes
into it's very hard i mean i don't think
people really appreciate that making a
movie is incredibly hard it's it
involves a millions of people and a ton
of money and a very high pressure kind
of situation I want to kill myself in
others every single day how I'm on set
yeah um well the thing about a movie is
that if done right it's like a
multi-million dollar corporation that
exists for a couple of weeks you know
and you've got 100 employees who've
never met each other and are only around
for five weeks motivation is difficult
especially when you do when you know if
you try to fire someone to takes three
weeks notice I mean not everyone is
sometimes you can fire people right away
but sometimes it takes a long time and
it's like you know they can wait those
things out you know I I never got a more
a greater appreciation of Michael Bay
than after I'd started producing a
couple of movies because I always
thought he was like you know his movies
are all terrible I still do but I really
appreciate what he brings to the table
which is that here's a guy who's got you
know a creative skills as well as the
skills was like a CEO who holds together
two hundred million dollars worth of
product that lasts for just like a short
period of time manages to crack the whip
and get everyone to do their job I was
not an easy feat so you know good as the
good as new Michael Bay I'm not gonna
see transformers three but you know
I understand why these guys have their
place in the landscape